[Music]
we're going to break in now uh to uh
bring you an event out of kabul uh this
is a live event with the uh taliban
spokesman zahidbullah mujahid who's been
speaking at a an event there uh
celebrating um the end of the u.s
withdrawal in afghanistan
uh afghanistan and also to extract the
mines
and natural resources from afghanistan
when they occupy afghanistan hey
americans we should not come to
afghanistan
don't occupy our country but they didn't
listen to us
is
and they also found some
is
who were on the side of our struggle
against the former soviet union
who were sympathizing with us or
supporting us one way or another
to them all i say we have regained our
independence
freedom
and there is no doubt
we will be faced with a number of
challenges
simply
because we have
different parties
[Music]
those
disputing factions were not serving
the afghan people
now we should live above
we should transcend above our
differences
come together
all they have gone from all factions
should join hands
to serve the people
and to serve the religion
this no doubt
requires a great deal of time
and a great deal of sacrifices
we should
join hands
together to march forward
to a bright future
as
within 10 days only
we managed to firm our grape
on all the afghan soil
from corner to corner
this wouldn't have been possible without
the fortitude of our fighters
and the support
of the afghan people
pledge
before you
that we will spare
no effort
to restore our national unity
and
to regain
our social harmony
steering away from any form of hypocrisy
or those who are trying to drive a wedge
among
our people
on the economic
front
since we regained our political
independence
we are similarly
in a dire
we
need to bring our economy back on its
feet
and
and that's why
we need all
the
experts and professionals
to step forward
come together join forces
and lay down
a road map for the future
[Music]
that we should live up to the
trust
given to us by the international
community
and any form of aid
given to us should be put into the right
channels
we cannot tolerate
anything
that would undermine
the national interest
at the same time we should all
supporting us
oh those who were supporting us over the
past years
if they see us fail they will not
continue
to support
afghanistan or the afghan people
[Music]
this is a must
we should
to the confidence of the international
community in order to be able
to attract
foreign investment
into afghanistan
who are willing
to come and invest in our country
this applies
not only to the economy but also to the
health and education sectors
of the upcoming government
the government will be a representation
of all the social fabric of the afghan
people
however
all those
community and namely the supporting
countries
who are
providing assistance to afghanistan
they will see us
failing to apply
of the afghan people
we will not even
blame you
customs official
gathered some customs duties
and all
the amounts were kept in his own drawers
out of his own pocket
and this is the case of all the afghan
people we
are here to serve the people we are here
to serve
the country the homeland
i go back to the economy
to all
investors
domestic
and foreign i invite you all
to come
and invest in afghanistan
all the possible positive atmosphere
will be available for you here
your investments will be in good hands
the country
will
be stable
and safe
a product of our own hands it is the
product of all
the afghan people we are all partners
in this victory
despite our political differences
this is always the case
[Music]
a new chapter we should bury the hatchet
we have no animosity against a
particular
faction
party
or individual
we transcend above this all right
this is a closed chapter of our history
we are all
looking forward to the future with one
eye one goal
our own people have been suffering for a
long time
to bring all our people together we have
been reeling for 20 years
under occupation
dire
and to all our afghan people of all
walks of life
[Music]
and you are part of
organs of this one
body
all the afghan people you are all our
countrymen
fellow afghan fellows citizens
fellow brothers
and each and every corner of this
country we cannot march forward into the
future
without your participation and your
support
all the afghan
parties
factions and tribes
will be represented in the government
we wish to continue to see our country
free
and independent
we have good relations with the world
community and here
i reiterate that we wish to continue
with good relations with all the world
states
and let the world community know
our stretching
with all the countries
based on
reciprocity
these concerns
and multilateral good relations
and at the same time
we wish that the international community
would not
interfere in our own domestic affairs
similarly
we cannot afford
to intervene
or interfere in any other countries
domestic affairs
we are marching forward into the future
towards more stability
peace
and healthy atmosphere we cannot
tolerate to see afghanistan once again a
battlefield
a source of threat or danger to any
country
similarly
we do not wish to see any threats
by the former soviet union
by the united states
we did not
trespass on any of these
countries
they were
and invading our country once again i
reiterate that we will stretch out our
arms to the whole world in peace and
harmony and cooperation i congratulate
you once again
it is a victory to afghanistan the
afghani people and to all the arab and
muslim worlds and peoples everywhere
so you've just been hearing there from
the taliban spokesman in afghanistan
mujahid
addressing
followers
at an event in kabul to celebrate the
the withdrawal
of u.s troops
they complete